اذا كنتم من عشاق المشروب الرمضاني الشهير
العرقسوس فربما عليكم التعامل بجديه مع
التحذيرات الطبيه من هذا المشروب
هيئه الدواء المصريه نشرت تحذيرا دعت فيه
الى عدم الافراط من تناول العرقسوس لما
يسببه من اثار جانبيه خطيره فبحسب التحذير
يقلل المشروب من مستويات البوتاسيوم في
الدم الامر الذي يؤدي الى الاعتلال العضلي
وعدم انتظام في ضربات القلب ويساهم في
زياده مستويات الصوديوم ما يؤدي الى
ارتفاع ضغط الدم والتورم
الهيئه قالت ان تاثيرات العرقسوس تزيد
خطورتها على الاشخاص الذين يعانون من
ارتفاع في ضغط الدم او امراض القلب او
الكلى التحذيرات من هذا المشروب طلب
النساء الحوامل ايضا فاستهلاكه المفرط
يسبب الولاده المبكره ويؤدي ايضا الى
مشاكل صحيه لدى اطفالهن
[موسيقى]